Oh, hi Santa!
Good morning! You know what, I can't even fake it.
Look, after the year we just had, the usual gifts...
...are just not going to cut it.
So, we have to find something else and fast.
That's all, figure it out, good luck.
What does that mean?
We are doomed.
What do you think?
Not great.
I should've thought about that before I said it.
Sorry, it's an old habit.
Elf Shopping Network.
Everyone wants a giant jumbo jingle bell.
No.
That's it.
I give you togetherness.
I figured it out.
We're going to gift the holiday spirit.
That sounds dumb.
No, Santa!
We're going to take all those family moments that make the holidays...
...and package them.
It's down to the wire.
The team's been working around the clock.
We had to rethink our whole approach.
I'm not sure it's going to work.
It'll work.
I didn't know you were listening.
That works.
This year has been harder than ever and yet,...
...somehow, you all found a way to pull it off.
You reminded us it's not about toys or the ornaments.
It's about the little things.
Santa? Santa, you're on mute.
I wanted to say thanks.
Thanks for believing.